you know there is a demo out in these
streets on that PlayStation five what is
going on
uh what's going on is I would actually
say
playing Final Fantasy throughout the
years you know
I would say the franchise kind of went
downhill after 10 12 was a that was a
good game but uh I would say 13 is when
the demise of Final Fantasy started
happening to me and then they decided
we're gonna make two sequels to that
damn game so uh that we got to play uh
13 to X2 or 13-2 and then third and then
Lightning Returns so I played 15 and I
felt like 15 was a step right into the
back in the right direction to you know
what the franchise is about but it
wasn't the right direction you know it
it was kind of like
we're completely going off the mountain
but we ain't going anywhere we just
turned around like we're still in the
same spot just right on the edge of the
cliff but I do think that you know seven
started to give me a little bit more
hope that you know they
this I first of all I want people in the
chat because I see this all the time on
Twitter this isn't an attack on whether
or not Final Fantasy is a turn-based
jrpg okay
this is an attack on whether or not
Final Fantasy lives up
to
what we as Final Fantasy fans expect
from the brand we expect fantastic
stories great character development in a
world that always has some form of
hidden agenda
and I I felt that a little bit in 15 but
not a lot
it was okay in 13 but there was no like
real good character development there
are some characters that did okay some
that didn't
but when I played 16
um
I still concerned but I went from
this is this game's gonna bomb to
okay maybe this game's gonna do
something
words in the IOP chat come on now say
what you said you said that's it
well no I mean obviously it could
definitely be in that game of the year
Contender now okay because to be honest
like we got six games that generally get
game of the year because they always do
one more than the rest so I mean you got
Zelda Starfield Spider-Man
Final Fantasy 16 Diablo most likely
Maybe
you'll have uh that Harry Potter game
uh maybe Hi-Fi Rush forgot about that
yep it failed so long ago
there's two spots that
it like look there's been quality games
that's came out this year like Resident
Evil 4 you know Dead Space remake but I
don't know if India because like I feel
like Resident Evil 4 is probably gonna
be on that list like when you come out
as a reboot you gotta really bring it
you know what I'm saying like and I
think final I think Resident Evil did
bring it but if a game like Final
Fantasy 16 comes out and it brought it
as a new game because every Final
Fantasy for the most part besides it's a
little bit of sequels they did like
Final Fantasy 10 they did a couple with
12. they did a couple of 13 they did
some DLCs of 15 like they generally are
on their own
World thing there's not like any direct
sequels for the most part besides those
couple exceptions that I said a new game
I think will get
that nomination before a remake the only
time I see like remakes doing anything
yeah well unfortunately I think there's
a good chance raising before remake well
you go boycott the one I would break out
there you ain't gonna spit the the uh
the same verse and do a different beat
on the track I just I feel like 16
definitely has a chance to be in that
game of their Contender but I don't
think it's gonna win because I do think
starfield's gonna hit higher than 16.
and I think Zelda if Starfield falls
short it's definitely gonna win it the
only the only contenders I could see the
only contenders I see 100 beating is
what uh that can have potential to be
Zelda is Starfield I don't see
Spider-Man or 16 having a climbing game
that we saw would be Zelda like oh stop
it's just like when it comes down to it
16 felt nice to get the combat felt
pretty good I would still
prefer turn base but this is a good
middle ground you know the the mixture
between summons you know for those in
the chat that that watch like Naruto
like they're pretty much like the
there's characters in this world that
are pretty much in Cherry keys they have
Demons Inside
So I I like that I like the the limit to
me Final Fantasy has always been at its
peak in the middle of a war you know
there's been certain games that has
avoided that but for the most part the
best Final Fantasy games is in the
middle of some conflict that kind of
starts at the beginning but it just goes
straight up in the Middle with his war
going on in this yeah so and you're in
full-blown War like literally one of the
one of the final fantasies that people
put like the top three like right after
seven right after nine right after six
is Final Fantasy Tactics
and that is literally the entire game is
about war
so it's just I think it's good man I I I
gotta see more of it I gotta see because
they kind of did this at 15 where they
did a lot of the marketing based off of
the summons and how the summons are
going to interact with the world yeah
but then when you play 15
that's sometimes
so it does look like because
the Summit is infused into a person
you're going to see more of that but
it's just like what they show me in that
demo
is that just gonna happen like once or
twice yeah or is that just gonna be a
frequent thing now we did see a couple
things like in the in in the directs
where we saw multiple of a variety of
summons fighting each other like
do you pick the summons that go out in
battle is it like a Pokemon kind of
thing it's like Titan I choose you I
don't know but I do feel like they
answered enough questions to make me
want to actually play the game to find
out no doubt so if you got some time in
the demo a little bit how will we feel
about that Final Fantasy 16
yeah like I jumped into it and because
because they said they said it was
essentially the start of the game right
and all of your progress should go over
to the main game right so I jump into it
oh real quick so when I played it and I
talked to you it's like one of those
things where you start in the middle of
the game it seems like and then they
like okay this is where we were now
let's go back and tell you how we got
here right and and to me that kind of it
it's great because it's a great sort of
Storytelling tool but at the same time I
was like damn I I just want to make sure
this is actually the beginning of the
game and I'm not gonna go into the when
I play the final product and it's
different and you told me to you know
transfer my save over because again I
don't have a lot of time to play so I
don't want to have it necessarily be
redoing stuff that I've gone through
already
um so I like the fact that it did start
abruptly though I thought okay wait a
minute it starts in the middle of
something then it goes back
um what I liked about it and I'm usually
not the dude that really is in for the
cliches and the things that remind me of
other things in pop culture like
obviously you see this you play this and
it definitely has Game of Thrones all
over it right all over it
um but the good thing about Game of
Thrones and what I really enjoy about
Game of Thrones is that they have no
respect for your reverence of a factor
they don't care that they don't care
like yeah if you're gonna die you're
gonna die
um and again I haven't played enough of
this to know that's gonna happen but
already with the attitudes I'm seeing
with some characters some characters are
like you can tell some characters are
overtly evil and then some characters
are just sort of you know they're Towing
the line and they have they have
intentions with which they may think are
pure but aren't necessarily so it's just
a matter of that stuff coming into play
it that's really going to grab me or not
the game the game looks beautiful
and looks absolutely gorgeous we talked
a little bit about the fact that the
performance mode isn't quiet in 60 and
you see a little bit of hiccups here and
there but in performance mode like I
switched over to the 30 just to see
where the graphical differences were and
I didn't really see anything substantial
at all like really like so run that at
60 if you can
um or performance if you can
um and then the combat a little bit that
I did see of combat I thought was cool
because again it's that middle ground I
thought ff7 remake was that middle
ground they gave you sort of a little
bit of the turn-based stuff right but
but slowing it down and allowing you to
sort of pick your stuff in real time
made it so you had to really think on
your feet as well so it was a little bit
of both and this is seems like it's
leaning more into the pure action and
when you have the combat director from
games like you know Devil May Cry 5 and
things like that you know what's funny
so in the first like two hours of like
well not two hours like the first half
of what I've seen in that demo yeah was
more character development in 16 than I
saw in the majority of 15. yeah that's
crazy a lot of people have you know
issues with 15 right and obviously for
the team that made 15 went on to make
four Spokes and they got shut down
unfortunately yeah
um so yeah this is Yoshi P right exactly
you know we had to say 14 from the death
exactly you know so uh and again I'm not
gonna sit here we we talked about the
the the hypocrisy that existed about
your you know when Yoshi P was talking
about why there aren't people of color
in this or whatever but we talked about
the fact that we're going to point it
out and we're still going to play the
game because that's our our job is to
play the game and that is the job so
we're gonna play the game
um and I'm excited to play the game for
what it is
um
and I there's nothing that I saw there
that really turned me off man that
really turned me off it it as a fan of
ff6
I kind of feel like
it's it's in that vein where that some
really horrific things are going to
happen in the middle of this game I feel
some World altering events I feel like
you've got good intuition okay stay stay
long for this ride it's it's yeah yeah
so I'm excited for it I don't know again
I'm never home so playing on my PS5 is a
pain
um unless you use the handheld I mean I
could only get as far as a toilet with
the handouts I mean you you do have the
Rock Island it has a streaming
capability together yeah but again my
issue is my my crappy working okay
I will literally be playing it at five
frames they don't have an option to
download them
so we'll see when I actually get to to
play it in depth but I'm excited for it
I am no doubt no doubt king um I know
this is not on Xbox but um you know it
gave us it's not a beta boy either
you know potential baby there's a year
exclusively maybe it comes to Xbox at
some point
I would hope my breath makes the Square
Enix is um sometimes do get purchased
out here in the streets we heard we
heard when you don't play ball with us
we buy it I did Twitter if they actually
bought Square Enix if we buy Square Enix
I'm gonna tell you right now that you
will see me take my PlayStation in front
of the screen and rip the Wings off
a kid making
[Music]
and making the the downloading it him
signing into him making the character
and he's like that's awesome yo shout
out to Paris great to finally be
cognatic person no doubt was a pleasure
brother see you in uh Pax West brother
Pax West we will see the whole team
pulling up the whole team did you get
your whatchamacall in the mail
um I Heard uh you get your Doctrine in
the middle
um
it was much easier upgrading the SSD and
the PS5 than it was I did open heart
surgery on this oh to get this job
to that genre the old dude that's in
there that's making people do stuff
that's a PC we know that's par for the
course oh my consoles we not supposed to
be opening them up and tearing out guts
and putting in new guts ah nah nah I'm
not about that man
no I'm not playing that thing until the
actual game comes out if I decide to
even get there right now D4
um has has me like uh like that like I
told you before that game has me I'm
going to play it at some point but I
also said that about the Final Fantasy 7
remake I don't like certain practices
and I'm one of those dudes that if I'm
standing on my Square I'm just gonna
stand on my Square pulse Square
I got that if if you really want me to
play your games make them available
someplace else but I do have a
PlayStation file right and I do I
brought my Playstation for exclusives
there's no way in hell a third-party
company is supposed to have exclusive
like well then then go over there marry
him so you just what'd you tell oh you
sound bitter you sound bitterness over
there because what it is is Sony don't
want you like that like obviously if
they ain't put a they put a ring on
Bungie and they still let Uncle for the
streets obviously they know that you
ain't worth the squeeze oh man like yeah
you do whatever and you keep on I'm
gonna be exclusive to you like this is
you know that
it's like no other he's like but you can
go out and date others like we are in an
open relationship and she's like but now
Sony
you just okay cause she don't like Xbox
like that she already an Xbox over there
like what up love he said you could date
she like um
I'll give you some stuff no no we want
the whole kitten caboodle no I don't
really like what's going on and I hope
Phil gets mad enough to just go over
there Snapchat
[Music]
just like everybody go in the building
and just plant an Xbox flag and then
he's like what's this you work for us oh
man this guy right here look it'll be
crazy if if they like they bought them
like after this if this let's say this
ABK though don't go through and I guess
there's like some new leadership or
something over there at uh Square Edison
they just walk up and they'll be like
here's a check I don't care what it is
write it in there and then let's say
they get that deal through quicker than
that because it would be a lot quicker
thing to get done yeah
they like they're like we're gonna put
this we're gonna we're gonna put rebirth
on uh on Xbox we're delaying it and um
it's not on Playstation anymore
and take us to court we'll see you in
court y'all messy look I give a boss up
quick
um look I was already sold on this game
prior to the demo they showed a lot of
it showed all the complexity systems
graphically looked phenomenal I'm like
I've already then they showed it twice
at the PlayStation case remember so I
was like all right we know I'm good I'm
I'm in I'm not gonna hold y'all at it
like because I knew it was on attic he
put a thing in our chat like yo we got
to talk about this there's a new
challenge it gave it at the game of the
year you know contention so to speak and
for me look this game is so iron lordly
let's just think that oh bro this is
none of that anime thing that you kid
this is Game of Thrones Final Fantasy
like it is your lord my like they in
that time but the thing that you gonna
like kid because y'all watch them anime
the Beast Indians of this thing called
the dominance like they running around
King it literally King they Runner
kingdoms are running around with human
weapons of mass destruction like bro
they literally it's like it looks like
the East got a dominant now to try to
compete with our dominant you know what
I'm saying I I think the reason that
like the disconnect is like they've done
that in Final Fantasy before but it was
before like the 3D era yeah so like you
you saw that in like 2D like little
Sprites like you're seeing that type of
energy now on the big screen and for me
and I know King gonna love it this is
not your your this is not your brother's
final fantas ain't your little kid's
final fan this is the sex buddy you're
murdered like the language like like I
saw a dominant grab up because in a
human form like come here girl right go
on the quote before the I'm like yo
squid this is unfiltered this is this is
I Final Fantasy after dark oh the
brutality the murder I might have
something to play in July yes I'm tell
King this is so you not only is it
lordly it is the most mature wildest
thing I've ever seen and then I'm gonna
tell you this let's go when Final
Fantasy the last one with the cars and
um
no I like that one okay so
I've ran out and got that game I didn't
wait for No Xbox I didn't wait for none
of that stuff but when it came on Xbox
it was day one it was day one but you
know you didn't play but it's cool
I don't believe it was yeah
but it was a problem with the Xbox
you know what the problem was it wasn't
a game
it was something that I'm telling you
guys I remember it was something that
made me say I'm getting it on
Playstation there's no way in hell
performance I think was baby yeah it was
performing I think it was digital
Foundry
nah I'm not doing that with this I think
so because there's no way in hell if a
game come out on both Xbox and
Playstation I'm going running by the
PlayStation version it was a reason why
I even think Xbox had the marketing
rights to it if I remember yeah but he
is right about performance
yeah because oh yeah shout out to Don
and talk he's right he said PS4 Pro was
out out and the 1X wasn't out at that
time that's what it was and I was
playing on my PS4 Pro yeah
bro I'm telling you right now look
graphically this game is gone here on
cinematics now yes it has a lot of
hashtag just what interactive movie
energy you know but for me it's really
telling God tier like sequences God
tier-like stuff and like I said like
soft point there is performance I put it
on performance mode it's a little weird
with the dips here and there my only
nitpick I'm not I'm with attic I don't
know if I'm sold on the combat yet
because I like the Final Fantasy 7
remake if they go action you put up your
spells and you got the little slow-mo
you're doing things in the mix and it's
feel more turn-based RPG this is
straight action shoot slash and some of
the boss is a little bullet bullet
spongy So In fairness to the game I only
play this demo I haven't seen the
complexity of the combat yet so I don't
want to say oh it's going to be just
this and simple I need to see more I
love the the evade addict I love the
evade and they reward you for the
evading stuff doing that but I'm gonna
tell y'all right now this story is so
fire and heartfelt this is one of the
best demos to sell you if you was on the
fence you are this gives me like the
story gives me like mad Final Fantasy 9
Vibes the it
spoil
you want when they you end the demo
you're gonna be like oh not nah
and then they they know they got it
because they thought they put the
pre-order they're like yeah so since you
like this little you got something bro
they had me like I know that it just
happened like that yeah more energy King
this is for you I'm telling you I know
how you get that yeah I'll talk to the
iron bank in July Talk to the I am back
sorry we got we don't never ask you
always put the money back in the podcast
I am baked cause we get King David this
place it'd be for birthday present yeah
oh yeah come on come on I'm not going
right now I'm I'm not going to allow
anything
you still have not played any Street
Fighters oh no no I've been playing
Street Fighter a little bit and I'm I
want to get back to uh fight night
Fridays
we're going to be getting back to Fight
Night Friday
but I'll spoil it
the voice actor for Clive yes
I know it's not like Calvin I know I'm
watching dub oh you didn't know words
here's the thing I always do I always
like multitask to like a huge degree I
just don't sit there and like I gotta be
able to hear and understand what's going
on so you went subtitude subtitles no I
I I listen dub is the English voice oh
no we did it the same I know you guys
are real big on sub like that
I left this before I'm good no no no I
didn't change anything no the only time
I got that option right I'm gonna sit
there and listen to it the only way I do
that is when it's a purely Japanese
setting like like a ghost Shima then
I'll do that because
we talking Bronx languages
[Music]
the only time I do it on anime is if
like something crazy happened and dub
I'm like I can't wait where is it and
stuff listen I'm with you though but
like I said I want to give the Clive
voice actor
his FL like this is one of the most
heartfelt and again without spoiling
please and the demo please complete the
demo Y'all Gonna understand there's
levels to voice act I already got this
dude already I haven't played again they
already won an Academy awarded Mama this
person is amazing so yeah salute to that
and that was all I was gonna say on that
before we got anything else
he has a lot of Jon Snow energy not a
Jon Snow yeah a lot of oh Clive did that
Clive did that I felt every moment from
Clive so yeah I'm there continue